so just what state are the UK's armed
forces in let's get an idea now with me
uh retired Air Vice Marshall Sean
bellshaw good to see you um let's get
into this shall we
um the UK not committing to spending
more money on the British Army and we
heard there from Deborah Haynes other
European countries are investing more
I think the the story we'll get the
facts behind it because defense spending
can measure in a number of different
ways but the the sort of internationally
recognizes the proportion of GDP in
other words how how much are you
prepared to commit NATO a set of two
percent Target and all the nations
within NATO have signed up to that
Target the trouble is very few of them
actually make it from this graphic here
you can see that UK is up at 2.3 percent
but the vast majority countries are not
what's happened is the war in Europe
which is right on the doorstep of many
of our European colleagues are suddenly
shaken them all up and they now
dramatically trying to increase spending
Germany for example was 1.4 percent it's
got a big gap to make up now as a
military guy of course I would always
welcome more National money for our
defenses but I have to say that the UK
on this metric is paying its way and if
you look at all of this area below the
graph of two percent that is the area of
spending which could make a really
significant difference to NATO's uh
um capability the other challenge is how
we spend our money we're clearly meeting
the requirements of NATO are there smart
ways we can make and spend their money
almost certainly and that will be the
use of simulation Network simulation not
just nationally but internationally
because we're going to be placing even
greater Reliance on alliances into the
future so when the PM says that the UK
has one of the largest defense budgets
it's because of that GDP figure that's
measured by and the other countries are
spending more to catch up let's talk
about the British army because that has
come into shop Focus today and the UK it
seems allowing the British army to
shrink in the past few decades why and
what effect could that have going
forward defense as we've heard from
politicians of all parties the number
one priority for for any government the
challenge is how you spend your money
and there's no doubt the British army
seen here training has been reduced in
size we're in down to 73 000 I think it
is but half the size it was 30 years ago
but of course the military is always
configured a by the threat but also by
resources but interestingly also how we
fight and the danger is Pebble is used
in the Ukraine war as an example of how
we need to reconfigure Russians are the
way they're fighting this is almost 20
Century it's almost Neanderthal because
they're hundreds of thousands of
soldiers on the ground unguided weapons
an attritional type of warfare almost
seeming not to care about how many
casualties they have whereas Ukraine by
contrast which is what the West does we
tend to use technology Precision Strike
weapons because we're very we try to
minimize the number of casualties we
have now when it comes to the size of
the army my Army colleagues would say
it's only the army that can take and
hold ground absolutely right but the
Nuance here is how much we rely on
technology versus very very large armies
defense is all about choices it's about
uh configure to the threat but within
the resource envelope that's available
yeah um army Personnel just one resource
other resources we know that the UK has
committed a lot to Ukraine whether it's
you know tanks or other artillery
equipment has that left big black holes
in the UK's own defense capability when
it comes to those kind of resources the
short answer is you don't keep stuff on
the shelf that you don't need so by
giving some of it away a you take
increased risk the challenge is do you
need to address that risk quickly or not
and that's and there's been a recent
report that says in the media that the
government's criticized it took almost a
year to start replacing some of the
equipment that's been given away but
let's use end laws as an example an
anti-tac weapon over 10 000 of these
have been given to Ukraine
um so we need to replace them now do you
replace them like for like just you
can't go to the shops and buy them you
have to configure industry to spin up or
do you look and say this thing was
entered service in 2009 it was being
developed 20 years ago Technology's
moved on quite a pace could you get an
upgraded model could you get better
capability and could it be cheaper so
undoubtedly getting value for money for
the taxpayer mod will have gone out and
try to find out whether they're
Alternatives and how best um to secure
those but let's be clear it's also not
just about equipment free credits
training as well literally overnight the
first batch of Ukrainian tank operators
landed in the UK to try and learn how to
fly operate the Challenger to they'll be
both operators and maintainers they'll
be using these sorts of facilities it's
not really expect a simulator look like
there's loads and loads of tank
simulators in there that there'll be
lots of operators they'll be in
realistic conditions they'll be put
under a huge amount of pressure but this
is some of the best training in the
world that will be provided to our
Ukrainian soldiers okay Sean thank you
fascinating stuff sure Builder with the
latest on the British Army and of course
events in Ukraine